cibole michel rivard fait un retour au
petit écran dans nuits blanches saga
familiale pourquoi ce retour au jeu le
retour au jeu est toujours chez moi
une fête parce que j'aime jouer j'ai
toujours aimé ça ça me rapproche
beaucoup de mon père ça me rapproche
beaucoup du métier que j'ai vu mon père
manier avec beaucoup d'aisance et
beaucoup de talent quand j'étais jeune
donc apprendre les textes de quelqu'un
d'autre me plier aux exigences d'un
personnage puisque
je vais fouiller dans nos archives à
l'âge de 7 ans vous décrochez votre
premier rôle
1958 ouais quels souvenirs gardez-vous
cette époque là c'était la série
s'appelait sévère c'est comme si une
magnifique et moi je fais si je ma
mémoire est bonne mon rôle est celui
d'un enfant qui s'est pris la pape dans
un piège et mon rôle consistait à gémir
goro de composition gros rôle de
composition parce que même à 8 ans je ne
vais jamais eu la pâte prise dans un
piège
donc j'ai dû m'imaginer mais je me suis
dit qu en fait il ya eu plusieurs rôles
à partir de sorts libye j'ai joué dans
rues de lens une série dramatique entre
entre
15 et 15 et 20 ans j'étais dans une
opinion mon père aussi d'ailleurs dessin
d'ensemble même certains moments est ce
que j'aimais pas tellement sûr parce que
moi déjà j'avais un pied dans l'alizé et
dans l'humour absurde sauge avoue bien
humblement je bats ma coulpe
je le faisais pour pouvoir m'acheter une
guitare par un ampli c'était la question
est ce que vos premiers rôles vous avez
fait pour celui des souvenirs avancé
avant ça c'était
j'étais plus jeune puis je veux
jamais j'ai jamais la sphère jeudi
rarement vu aussi énergique aussi
heureux est ce que c'est le succès de
l'origine des espèces est un projet qui
vous tenait tellement à 15
et j'ai l'impression de redécouvrir une
chaise rivard on dirait que vous avez
fait la paix avec quelque chose j'ai
fait la paix avec beaucoup de choses
avec certains aspects de mes parents
individuellement et ensemble et
aussi avec beau dommage aussi avec
toutes mes chansons ci
oh
la peine de laisser ce
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de bons rendements
d'années on honore
on a une espèce de prétention de dire ou
arrêter me gausser avec la complainte du
phoque en alaska l'écouté ce que je
viens d'écrire le fait
c'est important ce que je viens d'écrire
la prochaine chanson est importante
mais je ne dois jamais oublier pour que
qu'est ce qui fait que je suis encore là
aujourd'hui qu'elle sait que motiver les
gens à continuer à m'encourager et à me
suivre etc certaines chansons et je dois
jamais oublier ça je dois jamais oublier
ce parce que les gens qui ont remarqué
la main font que je gagne encore ma vie
à faire le premier album du groupe beau
dommage a été remixé où elle va être
éditée en 2022 ouais comment gérez vous
le patrimoine de beau dommage et comment
vous voyez ce remix âge là mais moi en
notant que en notant que ce n'est pas
ben arous mercantiliste a dit quand il
ya
un intérêt
artistiquement valable il y aura pas de
surprise mais comme et là on en est on
peut nous mettre alors on les assume
comme dans les rues mixage des beatles
par gas myton tout ce qu'on a c'est de
l'amour on a de l'amour qui nous permet
de dire il y avait trois guitares à ce
moment là où à il y avait quatre
harmonies de voix et c'est juste ça et
bouddha major 50 en 2024 voilà je peux
vous fassiez comme les rolling stones
mais c'est un concert sortir pierre dard
30 salle
honnêtement honnêtement est ici tous les
membres de beau dommage avait continué à
être vraiment
actif régulièrement
musicalement je dirais pourquoi pas mais
ces politiques des jeunes et les retours
qu'on a fait on demandait beaucoup de
travail beaucoup de d'eau dans le vin
aussi parce qu'on est très différent
et dieu merci ça réussit alors ne
prenons pas une chance je pense que les
shows de beau dommage sont de beaux
souvenirs pour tout le monde ceux qui
les ont vus et ceux qui les ont faites
cette entrevue l'oeuvre en mettant un
immense cadeau merci beaucoup c'est vous
voudrez voir
[Musique]